name awards name award
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everybody
it is my honor pleasure privilege and
poopy duty to announce meme Awards 2018
the very first note Remzi gaming moments
no breaches speeches just memes
goddamnit memes oh oh but Before we jump
into it dice as you guys know memes are
becoming harder to monetize I know the
great tragedy the Great Depression how
do i monetize memes
according to Atlantic the lifespan of a
meme has shrunk from several month to
just a few days we have so many goddamn
memes this year why you want more of you
gonna knuckles you just can't have
enough oh man I wish that would really
do the tricks on me man it's beautiful
we're living in the Renaissance the
reign of goddamn Rand his owns of means
you don't understand you don't know that
you're in the good old days when until
you left the good old days but I know
this is it baby and it's all thanks to
me killing them so goddamn quickly it's
all thanks to me that's right I have the
only pretend power
[Music]
Abbe cringe apparently Jesus Christ it's
been a great year of mean review I had a
lot of fun I don't know about you guys
but it's been pretty epic Lee that was
disgusting
but let's have a look back just for a
moment of where it all start
meme review me review welcome everybody
to my brand new show called mean review
the Internet
hasn't been the same ever since meme
review you know I really enjoyed doing
meme review getting all my videos
striked it's always a pleasure just
giving away everything you know the
Atlantic wasn't wrong it's harder than
ever to monetize memes but I'm not
giving up gosh darn it
yes I love freaking love means people
don't know this about me it's a fun
little fact but like memes is like that
Mike or center of my being before we go
into the very first meme Awards I have
one last dude one last duty of 2018 and
it's to cure that big chunga's big chunk
is I'm coming for you I met you were
sitting there big chunga's r.i.p big
chunga's is gone everyone on Twitter
when are you gonna review big chunga's
oh it's happening right now
big chunga's i love him can I just say I
love him he is so cute
15 characters who could defeat Thanos
big chunga's it's really is the perfect
name to sum up 2018 shake its I'm
kidding now this started off as a
reaction image on presenting reddit and
then someone photoshopped this image and
call it big chunga's for PlayStation 4 I
don't know by you guys but I'm kind of a
gamer I play this game it's a pretty
good game featuring Dante from Devil May
Cry oh yeah now a Facebook post from
someone that works on games up posted
that I just had a customer come into my
store sweet lady who was trying to pick
up a game for her son who works at a
Game Stop in another
eight and she showed me the picture of
the game and asked me if I had it in
stock big jungle well did you have it in
stock you know this is a stupid game
stop employees always hiding the best
games in the back but everyone knows you
just gotta sing the Bing get chunga's
anthem parade of them to pull that out
hey you got big chunks sorry
sold out chunka chunka chunka chunka
chunka chunka chunka chunka he'll go
tungo tungo tungo tungo tungo tungo
tungo chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga bigger
chunko chunko chunko chunko bigger chunk
oh it goes a little something like that
it's a secret
there's only one image on my computer
that's so unnaturally large that opening
it in my browser just about slows the
whole thing down to near halt unless I
exit the tab and it's this single effing
image big chunga's it's so goddamn big I
don't think people fathom how big big
chunk is really is big chunker's has
gotten so popular that they got a live
action confirmed with it and it's played
by Lee sings oh yes finally a real actor
playing a really important role I'm so
proud of this community I am so proud of
being a youtuber what are you so afraid
of you're an awesome body thinnest here
to make every shot count oh yeah big
chunga's isn't last of us big chunk o
Susan nice the last chunga's Wow can't
wait to play that one the chunga book
goddamnit disney bought it Disney bought
it it's over
well it's been fun guys damn level ten
bars damn skinny chunga uh-huh no thank
you
and no thank you big x86 Unga Bunga Wow
next mean we're getting into the meme
Awards guys I'm sorry but I gotta make
sure I round up this year properly
either I gotta make a proper good see
Bootsy otherwise what's the point
next up we have these goddamn awful
mobile ads hey actually I will say
they're the best they're the best okay
so here's what's going up
this guy just invaded my favor you
through more not prepared for it at all
scruffy look should have scouted me
middle a said he doesn't have anywhere
near enough troops and his army
composition is garbage how would you so
say that ears garlic once I do crush him
I'm going to capture his hero so once I
get his hero I can have the rats mitt
back or execute it for a buff for my own
army okay that's very cool
and they got a cute asian Avengers amino
so I'm just gonna send my cavalry
cuz I totally outnumber them they just
died what did I do wrong you gotta
change it to an arrow formation
I'll go what this is information and
suiting information but but is she going
to still win come on yeah yeah oh yeah
they wanna send in the cavalry
let's send them back I buy right here
from what I'm seeing right here is way
less troops animo is shooting arrows
from what I see here they got way less
troops this is so authentic I I really
you think I might win this one judging
from what I'm seeing right here is way
less troops and you know shooting arrows
the only thing that could make it more
authentic as well as if Lily sings was
acting in this that's the only thing
that I think would make it even more
tear breaking I mean all those soldiers
died you see how they change the
formation like how archers this is me
when I game with my epic pros now I'm
not sure but it isn't that the exact
same footage that that asian girl was on
walking with their shields huh oh you're
going down wait Reggie winning I told
you isn't it nice when Proust came
together hey nothing makes me happier
and seem to broach throwing it out at
lords or more Brown available now
download link in the description this
video is sponsored by Lord small bowel
innocent right away but if they wanted
to spend money on me
I would add a percent take it now we had
these goddamn awful mafia war ads that's
become a meme level one poor lucky poor
level fifty crook
cleverly 99 oh my god I have to download
this game right freaking now I'm not the
BFI you're free it's that easy guys
if you're ever in prison and the BFI
comes at you you know what to do
now what were they thinking where they
made these mobile ads I don't know but
he's working alright so we should have
like a mobile ad where like a guy's
level hundred right and then like he
gives all the way and stuff to like a
girl and then you see like he's level
like decreasing and then like the girl
is literally literally listening it
literally the girl would just merely
turn around and give away all the stuff
that she he literally just got to the
guy next to her like that would be a
good ad okay so he gives away the car
there mope oh my god that house
[Music]
now that's a good ad right there and if
you don't think that's a good ad then
you don't know ads you don't know ads
this is how life is perceived by most
people and la mafia game worse
understands finally a game that I can
relate to this is how life is level one
oh you are so poor just shoot the bank
just shoot that goddamn Bank please
marry me
why do toughts gotta be like that why
don't web and got a do you like that
it's like before I shoot the bang I'm
not so attractive but then I shoot the
bank and all the sudden all the sudden
all the women wants me hmm no I'm not
sexism but hmm okay whamon please leave
a comment down below well you have to
say in your defense
mmm we also have the car jump scare
weird time for
Mima wards 2018 oh this is the little
bands you guys see this there's still
official dance so if anyone else ever
does this dance I'm gonna cop we strike
you
[Applause]
the number one category you guys voted
on Twitter we got over 58 billions
responses 58 billion that's a lot of
people based food me and the nominees
are Tide Pods skedaddle ski-doo to
awesome popcorn chicken sprite cranberry
wow we had a lot of food memes this year
Burger King wada it's hard to swallow
pills or somebody touching Matt's buggy
and the winner is I actually don't know
I haven't you somebody attacked my
[ __ ] come over here come over here the
crazies won't anger dungus here you go
you burned it gosh damn it now what do
you wanna see
don't bother touch to my smoker
[Music]
next me this Saturday we had a year of a
lot of tragedies a lot of people dying
but what's more important is this what's
the saddest me and the nominees are
marvel disintegration roblox go commit
not a live man ninny a dying of ligament
this is so sad while Luigi not in Smash
and the winner is this is so sad
I mean you shouldn't probably should
have seen that coming this is so sad
this is so sad what do you have to say
this is so sad this is just sad
next mean science break so what are the
celebratory Mormont's of the
breakthrough on the means we have P is
stored in the balls we all learn
something new today I think we can say
I'm something of a scientist myself they
did surgery on a grave let's not forget
that it's math related to science I
can't believe this is even a category
all right we're running hit oh my god
it's so close I thought it was peeing
too store in the boss but it's not it's
surgery on a great god damn it all right
there you go surgery got pieces your
your Scylla carbage means you know that
you're basically the worst mean with
2018 if I had anything to say about it
but here you go enjoy your Oscar and get
out of my sight
get out of my sack our next category is
about Obama we've seen a lot of bombers
is here what's up with that
like what's up for that
guys we have Obama and we have a broom
gun we have your bomber and it's gone
so which obama is the best Obama oh my
freaking gosh which one is it gonna be
you
Obama okay all right Jesus Christ
this one is more important sorry Obama
no one cares gon be gone
the sexiest me sexy sex appeal always
haves in place it means everyone knows
this everyone but what was the sixty is
one of them all we have a last thick
girl
we have been small remember that one we
have Thanos some people like purple we
have bow sect or vessel 600 to 500 BC a
truce coun or my man my legend na broski
big changes junga junga and the sexiest
me award dos - oh god I hope it's
powerset cuz Bauer said this so freakin
tight man oh it is birthday okay bow
second
Bowser twins the sexiest need Thanos was
a close second
very good bear said I guess a lot of
people like what's up with that the best
meme song everybody we had muffin song
crabber a hit or miss I'm already tracer
megalovania diamond to cocina de spicy
Beck lasagna Howard Lee Union and
business America but which song really
took the place which song was the anthem
of 2018 oh wow
it's business anger yeah I mean
obviously people like their song because
of t-series and the whole thing I'm
actually having an acceptance speech for
my own award show for my own song but
goddamn but I'll take it
okay I I literally wrote [ __ ] lasagna
in an hour two hours that's all they
took I don't think anyone is surprised
by that but still I just try to think of
the dumbest lyrics I could possibly
think of and it actually sounded good so
I'm really glad you guys liked it I
would love to do more songs in the
future because it was so much fun I mean
Brad literally just went down to the
beach oh yeah I'm sure that's fine a lot
of effort and a lot of thought went into
this oh yeah thank you guys thank you
guys so much love you guys so much and
next moving on Worst mean of 2018
everybody which one took the price as
the worst I think this is probably the
most important no one really likes memes
it's not like I want to be here it's not
like you want to be here it's like every
award show ever you just kind of want to
get to the point okay so we have T
series t posing
hope that one dines for tonight article
13 surgery on a grape and Danish car and
their words mean of 2018 goes to
fortnight here you go everything's very
cool really surgeon and a grape didn't
win we have best meme show and best meme
left guys
okay best meme show we have meme review
mean review mean review meme review meme
review and options 6 well that's gotta
be a mistake obviously I think God meme
review ha ha ha
thank you guys so much it's gonna be my
honor to role means for another four
years
thank you I love democracy what can I
say now the moment we've all been
waiting for
the best meme of 2018 can you do this
Peter pie has no legs or bonus me wow
these are all pity pile related me what
have we in coincidence that's crazy oh
wow alright let's see which one wanted
oh it looks like can you do this it's
the meme who's been hit
oh wow thank you guys so much is my
honor I can't believe I won two awards
that's crazy that's awesome thank you
guys this is very epic I promise you
guys this is not gonna go to my head
like I'm still gonna be the same
level-headed grounded guy like I'm
not going to be like one of those people
like Willie sings that takes any
accomplishment and just think they're
the shiny okay as a special award as
well most which meme is most likely to
end the human race goes to the n-word I
just want to say a big old thanks to
everyone for an amazing 2018 you know I
kind of gave up on this channel but the
fact that you guys are still watching it
really means a lot to me it's been such
a blast this year and I hope and I can't
wait to see what 28:19 has to explore
thank you guys and I see you in 2019
epic bro Chris time
[Music]
you
[Applause]